[Music]
good afternoon great pleasure to welcome
you to the next in our series of curing
lectures we've had quite a few lectures
from experts in government from
academics from all walks of life
I'm Andrew Blake the institute director
and it's my great pleasure to introduce
today Torrey grapple from deep mind
I've known Tory for a long time he
trained originally in Germany as a
physicist but rapidly saw the light and
went to the Technical University of
Berlin to do his PhD in neural networks
with Obermeyer and worked on large
margin classifiers and rancors he then
did a postdoc at ETH and another postdoc
here in London with john shaw taylor the
renowned machine learning researcher
before joining the Microsoft lab where I
was also at the time where he did some
really very notable things one of the
one of the first things was working with
Ralph he briefed and Tom Minka on a true
skill where they used approximate
Bayesian computation to solve a very
tricky open problem at the time which
was how to do ranking of game players in
multiplayer games and you know the
problem is how you adjust the the
ranking of a player at each successive
game so that in the future they'll get
good challenges they'll meet players of
the right standard to make great games
so that was the true score system 2006
then he worked on some rather
groundbreaking systems that were very
influential in the company on how to
match people doing searchers with
advertisers that want to present
material in 2013 he was involved in a
very interesting and rather provocative
study where he along with some
researchers in Cambridge University
showed people just how much that about
their personality was revealed from
their Facebook profiles and just quite
ordinary things that you put on your
facebook profile machine learning can
show you actually says quite a lot about
you also in 2013 I found a quote from
Torre where he said that he had a
passion for the game of Go and for the
quest of developing a go engine that
plays as well as the best human players
and this was a remarkable prophecy
because a few years later working at
deep mind he and his colleagues did
exactly that in a remarkable work that
was published in nature last year that
undoubtedly stands as you've heard about
the alphago work so a very interesting
person Tory and therefore I'm completely
confident that this afternoon's lecture
on multi-agent learning is going to be
fascinating and I look forward to it
very much thanks
[Applause]
good well thank you very much for the
kind words Andrew and for inviting me
here I'm going to talk about a topic
that I'm very passionate about the role
of multi-agent learning in artificial
intelligence research and if I'm
successful today after the lecture you
would hopefully agree that it is crucial
to look at multi-agent systems in order
to make progress in artificial
intelligence the work I'm going to
present is all in collaboration with a
fantastic team at deep mind so maybe
just to start about deep mind you may
have heard of this company we have this
beautiful to word very ambitious mission
of solving intelligence and we would
like to do that to make the world a
better place and it is really these two
things that have attracted me and many
other people to work for deep mind and
it is in this context that I would like
to talk about the role of multi agent
learning so we have the notion of
intelligence here and it might be
logical to ask what is intelligence if
we want to somehow solve it artificially
right and of course this is a rather
open question and there's probably no
one definition that will capture this
very well but a working definition that
we're working with a deep mind is that
intelligence measures and agents ability
to achieve goals in a wide range of
environment and I hope it won't shock
you when I put this the most complex
formula of the talk right here in front
of you this is a the attempt of a formal
definition by a ligand Hatter of
intelligence and I would like to briefly
introduce you to this and explain a few
things about our methodology based on it
so the idea here is to measure the
intelligence of the policy PI
and we're defining it as the value that
that policy PI achieves in an
environment new and we average over all
possible environments new in some set of
environments or little wells if you like
and there's also a waiting sector which
basically says that the weight is two to
the minus the Kolmogorov complexity of
that environment and what that means is
that we really want to put more weight
on the simpler environments than on the
more complex ones there's a technical
reason this thing really only converges
if you have some kind of intelligence
waiting there but also it emphasizes the
ideas that we want a system that is
general and to start to be general you
want to start with the simplest tasks
and have a system that can cover a lot
of or maybe most of the simple tasks can
then move on to more complex tasks and
that's what's extract here but this
equation also gives us a nice
methodology because it essentially says
that we want to we want generality in
our intelligence intelligence isn't just
solving one specific thing but it is
solving a broad set of tasks and for
example you can think of this as an
example the set of 50 Atari games that
people from deep mind were able to learn
with deep reinforcement learning and
then this set would be those 50 games
and the idea would be to have a policy
that can can do well in all of these
games but eventually of course we would
like this environment to encapsulate
many more things so the most complex and
interesting environments that we can
find are multi-agent environments
because they're not just static and
follows a set of rules but they're
responding and that's really what
motivates our work in multi-agent system
more specifically I would like to
emphasize three points here one of the
the first one is that multi-agent
thinking can really inspire interesting
architectures because often it's a good
idea to break down the problem into
component sub-agents and that will yield
a more flexible system than having a
single monolithic system the second idea
that motivates this is that surely
intelligence didn't arise in isolation
there wasn't just one intelligent being
that suddenly became intelligence there
were groups of agents of animal later of
humans that through their interaction
came to be intelligent and finally if we
want to create artificially intelligent
agents that are useful and beneficial in
this world then we they will need to
understand agency they will understand
understand what we wish them to do and
they need to understand how to interact
with all the other agents in this world
be that people be that other AIS or be
that organisations for example so if we
dive into this the question of multi
agent designs of course has been
explored before for example by Minsky in
a society of minds but you can also
think of an organization as a multi
agent architecture for example the US
government is composed of many
institutions that in turn comprise
people that fill certain roles and so on
so it really is a multi agent design and
there are certain advantages to this
kind of design typically multi agent
designs are more robust than single
monolithic designs because if there's an
agent failure that can often be
compensated they're scalable in the
sense that you can add more agents to an
organization or to an architecture and
and have it grow in that way you don't
need to redesign the whole thing and you
might also be able to reuse or
reconfigure the constituents in
different ways there's also challenges
of course one of them is that you might
for your system have some kind of global
goal yet the agents by to only have
local actions and local visibility of
the problem and so that's one of the big
challenges to overcome there's also the
problem of incentives and credit
assignment if you think about an
organization how do you incentivize
people and similarly if you think about
the multi-agent system how can you give
those agents the right reward
such that together they satisfy the goal
or they reach the goal that you would
like the system to satisfy finally if we
think about learning problems then of
course if you have multiple agents
interacting and each one of them is
learning at the same time that means
that the environment seen by one agent
is constantly drifting because the other
agents are learning and that's true for
every one of those learning agents so
that also poses challenges now the
second point that I made is that we live
in a multi agent world and there are
just so many multi agent aspects to it
if you think of these different systems
that all involves multi agency if you
think about these tasks here agents need
to compete they cooperate they
coordinate with one another they
communicate they have to predict each
other's actions in order to be
successful and so on and just to give
you an example of how deeply embedded
these ideas are in our own minds I would
like to show you this little video it's
really just a bunch of geometric figures
moving around on the screen but if you
try to interpret what's happening think
you will get the idea
so the story goes on and on
but I think there's probably nobody in
this room who did not project some kind
of agency on these simple geometric
figures let's just how we interpret
these these things of our minds are made
to do that
this course is very early study 1944
from Heider and Simmel so finally
there's this idea that human
intelligence or intelligence in general
certainly didn't arise in isolation and
that there's a cumulative cultural
effect at work here as well so there's a
competitive side to this say humans
would have competed with other species
within our species with other tribes
individuals would have competed and so
all of these this competitive pressure
created ever-increasing task
difficulties to which the mind needed to
adapt similarly there's of course the
importance of cooperation the other side
of the pole where the whole evolution of
culture can be understood as a
cooperative phenomenon where people were
working together where groups of humans
were successful because they were able
to more effectively work together
leading to the beginning of institutions
of states and so on and and there's a
very fascinating direction I will not go
into this more deeply of cumulative
culture because if you think about it
there's not just the intelligence of the
individual that we need to approximate
if you like or to build but if you put a
human being into the woods alone what
can they really do it is all the
cultural context or the inventions that
have been made before the effect that we
can share work and special specialize in
certain tasks that that make us so so
powerful in this world ok so one thing
about discriminative culture that I
wanted to mention because I just find
that so fascinating is that really the
things that
people discovered in the past in this
example certain mathematical fields or
ideas that happened over a long period
of time as you see here thousands of
years from the past into the present and
if you then look here at what age these
ideas are taught to children then you
see here this this linear trend so the
older an idea is the earlier we teach it
to our children because these ideas
build upon one another and this is just
one one view on this idea of cumulative
culture that so powerfully fuels our
living on this planet good so for the
remainder of the time I would like to
talk about two topics the first one is
about one of the poets learning to
cooperate and the other one is about the
other pole learning to compete at the
first one here is work with Joe Lee beau
Vinicius Lombardi mark lang - and
generational scheme and it deals with
the notion of sequential social dilemmas
so let's dive into that getting people
to cooperate isn't always easy and the
way we can study this is through the
notion of social dilemma so the idea is
that social dilemmas of situations where
any individual may profit from
selfishness
unless too many individuals choose the
selfish option in which case the whole
group loses out I think we probably all
been in this kind of situation before
and these situations exposed to expose
the tension between collective and
individual rationality because as a
group we would want to do one thing but
as an individual we might want to do
something else and there are a number of
examples here
maybe best-known the tragedy of the
Commons public goods sharing Free Riders
you know people going on the Underground
without paying resource depletion voter
turnout pollution all of these are
problems
that can be described in this type of
framework and that maybe we can
understand better in this type of
framework and and find solutions to in
the systems that we design and the main
question that we ask in this field is
despite all these obstacles essentially
human selfishness if you like can
cooperation emerge and be stable so one
way this has been studied in the past is
the idea of a matrix game social dilemma
and the idea here is to really get to
the Drosophila of this problem the
simplest possible game that exposes
these ideas and these games are
typically two player games a different
player can either cooperate or defect
and this is a role player and the
colored player here and this is the
so-called payoff matrix where this
number R here tells for the role player
how much they get in terms of rewards if
they cooperate in if the other player
also cooperates so we call this here the
reward this is the penalty for mutual
defection and then we have the the
sucker payoff which is the if you
cooperate with the other agent effects
and the temptation which is the payoff
that tempts people to defect in the
first place and there are certain set of
inequalities between these numbers that
need to hold in order for this game to
represent a a social dilemma and there
are these two technical terms that will
be important in the future one of them
is greed it is if this temptation is
greater than this reward then players
will be tempted out of greed to defect
and there's also this technical notion
of fear which is if this punishment here
is greater than the sucker payoff then
you would be tempted also to to defect
but this time out of fear and not out of
greed okay so that's basically the
anatomy of the kind of problem we're
looking at
what are examples of such games here's a
game called chicken I will not go into
the details but the idea is basically
two cars are driving towards each other
and either player could evade and go to
the side and if neither of them does
that and an accident would happen but if
they both but if they that's this cell
here but if they both were then
everything is fine but it's even a
little better if you could go straight
and the other guys avoids you and so
that then gives these undesirable Nash
equilibria that this game tends to go to
work and here's another one it's called
stag hunt the ideas that people could
cooperate in order to find a great
reward but they might they might be a
smaller reward that they could go for
that tempts them to go there and they
might do this order fear that the other
agent might do it and that they would be
better off to do it as well if in order
to advise avoid this zero and to get
that one so this one is an example of
greed this is an example of fear and the
last one combines the two and this is
probably a game that many of you will
know it's the well-known prisoner's
dilemma where which is driven by both
greed and fear so essentially there are
these two prisoners and if they work
together they can they get to a positive
outcome because they don't act as
witnesses against each other if they
both act as witnesses then they will go
to prison both for a longer period of
time but there's this temptation to
betray the other one in the hope that
they will cooperate and and that's
expressed in these off-diagonal elements
and so this particularly delicious is a
game theoretic scenario because there
are these two forces greed and fear that
act upon the agents okay
so much for that but then this system as
simple as it seems these ideas has been
used
many fields to look at how cooperation
arises and there has been different
studies for example about how norms
might arise within such systems what
happens in social networks the idea of
reciprocity how can you in a repeated
game make the other agent cooperate and
so on and it's been an incredibly
successful model however there are
severe limitations to this model and of
course it is mostly this one-shot nature
of the game that's not really how our
life works right when agents make
decisions these are typically
temporarily extended it's not just a
single decision it's a sequence of
decisions cooperation and defection
which are just single labels in this
game really our entire policies that you
need to play out in order to implement
them cooperativeness may also be a
graded quantity it's not clear that
there's just cooperate or defect there
could be behaviors that are in between
these two then if you model this as just
an simultaneous decision between the two
players you're missing out on all of
these deals behaviors where you can
first see what the other seems to be
starting to do and then adjust your own
behavior and so on so there's really a
much richer dynamics in these systems
involved and finally usually there's
also a situation of partial information
where the agents do not have full
knowledge of what the other agent is
doing and so the idea of the work I'm
presenting here on sequential social
dilemmas is to address these
shortcomings and the idea is really to
capture the essence of these real world
social dilemmas but maintain this mixed
motivation in which agents do not have a
clear path towards collaboration or
competition but somehow need to find
their way between in this tension and
the methodology that we use is for these
SSDs the sequential social dilemmas is
that we have we defined games
quencher games and we train agents using
deep reinforcement learning to behave
within these games and to learn to
optimize some kind of reward and the
algorithms were using I will not talk
about them in detail are very similar to
the ones that were for example use in
the study on Atari games the dqn
algorithm and we will then be interested
in using this as a model in the social
science sense of how these learning
rational agents interact within these
environments and we will draw
conclusions about about such agents okay
so here are two of the games that we're
studying studying here the last one is
called gathering and the right one is
called Wolfpack and the idea of
gathering is that there are two agents
and they're really just a blue and the
red pixel here and these agents they get
reward when they eat these green apples
and they can also tag each other with
this beam which might take out the other
agent and the other agent that needs to
pause collecting and that gives some
time for the for the tagger to get more
apples but there's no reward for tagging
you only ever get rewards for eating
these apples the second example that
we're going to use we call Wolfpack and
the idea is that these red agents here
you can think of them as as wolves and
they are trying to capture this target
here which is moving about and the idea
is that when they capture it together
they will get get a higher reward
because then it will the the it will not
be scavenged by other animals because
they're together whereas if only a
single wolf gets the target then the
reward will be net and these two setups
or games if you like they differ in a
crucial point that we'll explore a
little later because in this game it's
actually easier to cooperate because you
can just ignore the other H
essentially and just collect apples
whereas in this game it's easier to
defect it's easier to go for the play
alone rather than to coordinate doing it
together and we'll see the consequences
of that but clearly this is something
that can only be expressed in the
scripture and framework and would not be
expressible in a simple matrix game now
in order to make the connection to to
the previous literature we thought it
was crucial to see if these games
actually correspond to these traditional
game theoretic views on social dilemmas
and so we took for example The Gathering
game here and we did what is called a an
empirical game theoretic analysis of it
we picked two policies one of them
cooperative and one of them defecting
and we let it play against two other
cooperatives and defecting policies to
fill in a little square matrix with the
expected rewards and that tells us how
well does the co-operative policy does
do against another cooperative one how
well does it do against the defective
one and so on and then we can analyze
this little matrix in the game theoretic
sense and figure out if it corresponds
to any of the known game theoretic
social dilemmas and what you see here is
basically that for gathering yes it is
the case that there are quite a few
instances in which this game corresponds
to a prisoner's dilemma and for the
wulftec game we find instances of the
prisoner's dilemma as well as the stag
hunt game and the chicken games in
different configurations of this game so
we have a direct link between this
ritual world in which we can look at the
sequential dynamics and the matrix
theoretic world where we can apply
standard tools from game theory now I
want to give you just a flavor of what
kind of results you can get here because
now because we're in this ritual
learning
not just in a simple environment where
we pick one of two actions we can study
different sectors that influence the
emergence of cooperation and so if we
first look at the first row here this is
the gathering game the one where you
collect these apples you can see that
for example if you change the discount
factor of the reinforcement learning
algorithm the one that determines our
long term your planning is that for
longer term planning this actually leads
to behavior whether it's more tagging in
the year in the action when you increase
the batch size you give them longer
memory it leads to a decrease in the
amount of tagging that's happening and
similarly in the wulftec game here we
are looking at the lone wolf capture
rate so how much these wolves have a
tendency to go capture alone rather than
work together we find the same
dependencies if we have the higher
discount rate then there will be more
lone wolf captures and if we have the
lower one there will be less and
similarly for the batch size so here
these games behave in qualitative very
similar ways with regard to these
learning algorithms but if you look at
this last plot you'll see a difference
because now here we're varying the
network size essentially the
computational capacity that we give to
the neural network in order to learn the
policies involved and here you see blue
is the larger network size and red is
the smaller network size so the agents
with the larger network size have the
capacity to represent more ricksha
policies and you can see here that in in
this case this leads to to a higher
level of tagging for the larger network
case in this game of gathering but in
the other games the higher network size
actually leads to more teamwork and less
lone wolf activity so this is just an
example of how you can now study what
impacts different aspects of the
environment or of the learning algorithm
have on the emergence of the cooperation
in these types of games so just to
conclude this part part of the talk
these sequential social dilemmas clearly
have a lot more interesting dimensions
that we can look at and in particular if
we look at learning because we're
studying these learning algorithms that
we put into these systems the
interesting thing is that these
algorithms do not just learn how to make
those decisions they don't need to learn
how to efficiently implement them so one
of these wolves cannot just say I will
now hunt together with my other worlds
but they have figured out a way of
actually doing it and learning it in the
presence of the other wolf that's the
second thing
effective cooperation policy is really
much easier to learn if the other agent
also cooperates right if they don't even
try to cooperate then it would be harder
to learn that and that's a phenomenon
you can only study in this situation
another point is that sometimes there
are coordination subproblems so we might
all be agreed that we want to work
together but now we need to figure out
how to do it together we need to
coordinate our actions and and that can
be studied in this framework as well
there's also the idea that there could
be different implementations maybe
there's different ways of working
together in order to achieve a goal and
I'll give you an example here from our
wolf pack game which is the idea that
there's really two ways of for these
wolves to capture the target together
one of them is that they always stick
together and only when they're near the
target will they then surround it and
the other one is that if they both go
separately and when one of the Wolves
finds it it will wait for the other wolf
to come and then they'll capture it
together so there's different ways of
implementing cooperation and this
framework allows us to capture that okay
so we've learned how to cooperate and
also we have learned something about how
to cooperate
and the second vignette here will be
about the question of how we can learn
to compete and again of course we're
talking about the multi-agent problem in
this case two agents a black player and
a white player in the game of gold and
this is joint work with David silver
edge of Wong and fantastic alphago team
at deep mind so the game of gold I
actually wish I had an hour now and
could all sit you all down with little
go boards and teach you how to play this
game it has a server show of hands who
actually knows how to play go see we
would even have enough teachers to do
this we have to try this next time so
now I just have to convince the rest of
you what a fascinating game this is so
the game of Go is over 3,000 years old
there's an estimated 40 million players
in the world and there's a staggering 10
to the 170 different goal positions now
we often say that's more than the atoms
in the known universe but the truth is
and I know this audience can take the
truth if there was a universe for every
atom in the known universe it would be
similar to the number of atoms in that
collection of universes
that's how complex it is ok
so why is the game of go so difficult
what makes it so hard it's actually not
only difficult for computers it's pretty
hard for humans as well well the most
obvious point is maybe the game tree
complexity of the game because in any
given position there's so many different
moves you can make in the game of course
it is played on this 19 by 19 grid with
black and white stones and so the first
stone that black places on the board
which is empty there's 361 different
moves that could make ok there's some
symmetries but roughly and then white
can make 1 of 360 remaining moves and so
on and that
to this huge complexity so the search
space is huge and it is difficult
therefore to enumerate all the
possibilities and do a min/max search
which would be the standard procedure
for smaller games the second point is
that it's also incredibly difficult to
evaluate a given goal position and say
if it is favorable for black or for
white
this is particularly obvious for
beginners when they see a physician I
think but even from for advanced goal
players it is a very difficult skill to
do this just to give you an idea about
the game space complexity again this is
an illustration of the complexity of the
game of chess and there's maybe an
average of 20 different moves at every
stage that needs to be considered at the
game of chess and then if you compare
that to the game of Go where there's you
know 3 under different moves to be
considered that's just vast and it's
this vastness of the game tree that
really motivates our approach to this
problem and the idea is that we want to
use neural networks and train them to
reduce the complexity of this search and
we do this in two ways
one network we call the value network
and it takes the goal position and it
gives us an evaluation of how good that
goal position is from from blacks point
of view or from whites point of view
essentially something like a winning
probability and the architecture of this
neural network is that of a multi-layer
convolutional neural network I'm sure
you're familiar with the basic idea
these neural networks take into account
translational invariance of the of the
of the inputs by having these little
windows that they effectively shift over
the input and they have shared weights
and this is propagated up all the way to
obtain the evaluation so in other words
it's really a simple mapping from an
input the image if you like or some
representation of the board position to
a number between 0 and 1 that tells us
how likely it is that black will win ok
the second ingredient is what we call
the policy Network and the policy
network is also a mapping
that takes the position as into it but
as output it gives us a probability
distribution over all the possible moves
on the board and so what this represents
is in some sense the intuition of the
goal player when I as a go player look
at the board I wouldn't consider all of
the moves as being equally plausible I
would have some idea that some moves
would look better than others and that's
what we're trying to capture in this
policy network and so we train it on
pairs of positions and moves and
fortunately go players often record
their games and if you have a recorded
game then you have many pairs of
positions and moves played and you can
learn this as a multi-class
classification problem effectively so
how do we use these now go and coming
back to this vast game tree that we were
talking about earlier which has a
fan-out of roughly 300 so this is really
just to hear because of the limitations
of the of the illustration here so we
have this vast tree that we would have
to expand in order to arrive at the
truth of the best move and now given
these two neural networks we can reduce
the depth of this search because while
without those neural networks we would
have to play to the end to evaluate as
black or white wins
now with the value network we can
evaluate much earlier if black has an
advantage or white has an advantage and
hence we can save all the time that we
would need to search this vast space
down here now at any move we also don't
want to look at all the possibilities
and that's where the where the policy
network comes in because for a given
move we might already have a pretty good
idea of what the good moves are and we
can effectively make the number of moves
that we look at the branching sector
much smaller using the policy network so
a lot of work in that project then has
gone into training these newer networks
and I just like to show you how this
works and our starting point which was
absolutely
for this project was a set of human
expert game records and their online
servers that where people play a lot of
go and they logged the games and we were
able to tap into that resource so we
have a lot of game records and the first
thing that we did was we trained the
supervised policy network simply as a
classification problem position is the
input move played by the strong player
is the output we learn the mapping cause
it's crucial to have generalization to
be able to have a new never seen
position and to be able to find a good
move for that when I first joined
deepmind
Dave silver invited me to play against
the very first version of these trained
policy networks and I thought how
difficult can this be it's just a neural
network right but you can imagine we are
surrounded by my new colleagues the
first few move seemed easy but slowly my
position started going down the drain
and I will never forget the many friends
I made that day everyone knew me by then
right he's the guy who lost an ego
against a neural network yeah okay um
now comes a crucial part here because
we're looking at the multi agent
scenario and what's happening now is
that we can take this now very fast
policy network that we've already
trained and we can let it play against
itself and because it's been well
trained we can we can now produce
relatively high quality games and we can
do it fast we can create a lot of them
and we can do reinforcement learning on
these now because we can see for a given
game if black or white wins and then we
can reinforce the moves that led to the
win and we can remove that led to the
loss and in that way train the system by
self play and the beauty here of course
is in the multi agent sense that we can
really only do this because the system
can play against itself and as it
improves both sides improve
and so there's this beneficial
improvement through the self play
process so we then generated a lot more
soft play data putting on the order of
30 million games and then we were
finally in a position to Train the value
network because now if you have games
you can extract a position from a game
you can look at who won black or white
and you can now train this system again
simply as a classification problem or as
a logistic regression problem to predict
what the winning probability in a given
situation is good let's look at a few
more details of how this training works
so for the supervised learning of the
policy network we have this twelfth
layer convolutional neural networks we
have roughly 30 million positions from
from human expert games we filtered
those to get games from really strong
players of course we didn't want to
imitate weak players and then we're
really just maximizing the likelihood by
stochastic gradient descent so what this
basically is we have the probability of
making a move in a given position
parameterize by Sigma and what we're
trying to do here is we're trying to
adjust the parameters of the neural
network such that it becomes more likely
that it would play the moves observed in
the training sample so the second thing
here is the reinforcement learning of
policy networks that's the thing that I
characterized as self play
so here again we use the same
architecture but now the the network is
playing against itself and we call the
outcome of this game of a given game set
and so we're now waiting these updates
by this outcome so if black wins the
game then we will give more weight to
the black moves and we'll make the the
white move that led to a loss will make
them less likely and so this led to a
very strong policy I think this was the
one that I lost again
I have to get myself some credit it was
a purely supervised one and finally the
reinforcement learning of value networks
the idea here is that this is the value
network it represents the value of this
position F and this parameter F I theta
and the nice thing is that we know the
game outcome because we have the full
game and we can use that game outcome as
the target and we can adjust our
parameters such that the value network
is more likely to give the correct
prediction of the game outcome you can
see here that many of these things were
quite compute intense and we were
fortunate to have those resources
available to us and this evaluation
function that we trained here was really
the first strong evaluation function
that has ever been devised for the game
of goal in the past they have been hand
attuned or people had tried to train
them in very simple ways but this
evaluation function really worked it it
can predict relatively accurately how it
who is favored in a given goal position
okay so now we have these two neural
networks and we need to understand how
we can integrate them into the search of
course the policy network alone would
already be able to just play because
given the position you can sample the
move from it or take the move with the
highest probability and it will make a
move but that's not and we can do better
than that by combining the policy
Network the value Network and Monte
Carlo tree search and just to explain
quickly how that works at every edge in
this tree that we expand we're
collecting information about how how
well this move did and that's the
combination of this queue and of our
prior which is provided by the policy
network so we have some a priori belief
of how good the move is but we will also
use evidence from how well it turns out
in the tree in all
to see how good it is and then we pick
for our expanding the tree the sum of
these two terms to figure out which
position to expand next and that gives
us the next position here and the first
thing that we do is we evaluate the
policy Network on it to find the next
edges or the next possible moves that
could be plausibly made or that experts
would made in this particular make in
this particular position we also
evaluate the value network on it in
order to figure out how good this
position actually is and we do a third
thing which is we play a random roll our
to the end of the game and record if
black or white wins that game and this
goes back to the Monte Carlo tree search
methods that had up to this point being
the strongest contender for producing
the best ago programs and which has led
to strong amateur gold play ok so we've
now expanded this tree we've done these
rollouts we've evaluated our networks on
the resulting positions and the last
thing we need to do is we need to back
up all of this information in order to
figure out which of the available moves
in our root position is now the one that
we want to play the best one and it's
really a simple averaging exercise in
which we propagate this information up
the tree to figure out what the value of
this position will be versus that
position say to make that decision at
the root of which move to play and
that's really all there is Monte Carlo
tree search combined with the value
network to do early evaluations and the
policy network to avoid expanding
nonsensical moves but to focus the
search on the plausible moves good
another important element of such a
project of course is evaluation and we
put a lot of energy into good evaluation
and in order for you to understand
what's going on let me explain how you
evaluate the playing strength of go
players let's you typically done on this
traditional q-dance scale
so at the bottom here you have the
beginners the Q's this is similar to to
a system as in karate for example and as
you become better you will then advance
to the one down level which is the first
master level and that goes up all the
way to nine done and then for
professional players there's an extra
scale from 1 P to 90 which are the
professional down levels and that's
roughly here so that's the scale we're
using and we also use an e low scale
because that can be more easily
evaluated quantitatively and now in some
sense from going from right to left here
you see the history of computer goal
because at the beginning there were
programs like new goal which try to
combine search with some handcrafted
heuristics and other other ideas but
never really took off and never reached
a decent level here then there were the
first Monte Carlo tree search program
for example Fuego or pachi that
eventually did break through the one
down level which is this strong amateur
level or maybe not that strong but ok
amateur level everyone down there I'm
bit careful and then there was this new
generation of programs based on Monte
Carlo tree search then and crazy stone
that reached really strong amateur
playing strings and this is the level of
alphago as we published it in nature the
beginning of last year and you can see
that it is quite a bit above the
computer programs that were available at
that point and reaches into into the
professional done levels here and you
have to imagine that this version v 13
that beat the other computer opponents
494 out of 495 times so this is this was
seriously better than those previous
programs
and then later when we were preparing
for the match against Lisa doll that you
may have heard about we had this v18
version which would then beat the
earlier version v 13 by giving it
several handicap stones these are moves
that the black the weaker player can
make on the board before the stronger
player even engages and so that this
program was this version was
considerably stronger than that one now
the problem of course is that these are
just internal evaluations that we're
doing and really we needed validation
against humans as well and so whereas we
had this evaluation against these
programs and by self play what we were
missing is an evaluation against humans
and that's where our european go
champion fun way comes into the story
and we evaluated alphago against fun way
who is a too damn professional player
and the strongest player in europe and
in this match alphago beat fun way 5-0
fun away was a fantastic opponent he
later joined the alphago team to help us
improve it even further because he was
had just developed such a deep
understanding of the problem and of
alphago in the course of this match but
at this point he definitely didn't want
to lose and it was very was very
exciting and then finally in March 2016
we felt ready to challenge maybe the
strongest player of the game of go
currently Lisa doll he's a South Korean
player and he has been dominating
tournaments over the past 10 years has
an incredible track record you can think
of him as the Roger Federer of goal you
know that kind of consistency and
and style and so we had this very
exciting match in March 2016 where
alphago won four to one against Lisa
doll which was a beautiful result it
cost us a lot of sweat as you can
imagine because then when that one game
did go down it was very exciting for us
of course we also feel a great deal of
respect for these players and so we in
some sense we were also happy that that
they were able to score this success but
on the other hand you can imagine that
when you work so hard on the project
that it can be can be very exciting to
see this kind of thing unfold okay and
as a result by the way alphago then
received the official 9 dan professional
certification from the Korean
Association so I just want to there were
many nice and interesting moves being
made in this match and some people even
argue that some sense of creativity of
innovation really emerged from from
alphago's play and certainly the
professionals that we talked to our
really excited to learn from alphago and
figure out new things about the game of
go here in this position here at game 2
alphago played this particular move here
and it was really quite interesting to
see we had a professional commentator
and he he saw the move he put the stone
down said oh no this probably wrong this
can't be true and so he then looked
again said well now that is actually
what alphago played this moves here and
he was a bit puzzled and eventually
through analysis he began to understand
what a profound move this is and it's a
bit hard to explain this here but just
to maybe the idea you see in go you can
work on the third line and if you have a
row of stones then this
territory that you make count towards
your final score and it's a very good
thing to do you get territory and you're
making you using the edge of the board
to get it now you can also play on the
fourth line these stones or examples of
that one two three four and that gives
you influence towards the center and
that's also considered to be a good
thing maybe you can build a big
territory in the center but playing such
a shoulder move as we call it on the
fifth line is very unusual because you
should be afraid that white builds a
wall like this and gets a lot of
territory on the side and so go players
would naturally reject that move and say
that can't possibly be good probably
because their master children that it
can't be good which their master
children and so on so here comes also go
place this move goes on and wins the
game and it was one of the many
innovations that that I think human
players are now picking up from alphago
to improve their own game more recently
we had a little adventure because we
wanted to launch some test games online
to see how much progress we have made
since then and so a Jeff Wong from the
team he played 60 games online against
different professionals mostly the top
professionals in the world most of them
have online accounts and they also play
play go online on go servers and there's
were they were relatively short games
was 20 seconds to move but the
remarkable thing was that
alphago under the name of master and
McGee ster ended up winning all 60 of
these games and whereas at the beginning
people were didn't weren't quite sure if
this was also gold or some other program
and so on when when it came to 60 mill
there were thousands of people on the
servers watching these games unsold and
so on
and it was beautiful to see and also
these 60 games are now a phenomenal
resource for the NGO community to study
the way the way
alphago place and for example a
grandmaster ghuli said that together
humans and AI will soon uncover the
deeper mysteries of goal so they've
really taken on board
alphago as a possible tool where AI and
humans can work together to understand
something like go in a deeper way than
ever before I just want to give credit
to the alphago team this phenomenal
bunch and recently some more people have
all done a fantastic job in working on
this project and I would also like to
emphasize that in order to solve such a
hard problem it also is necessary to
have a lot of very good people working
on it so this is not a small little
project this was a major effort and it's
been an incredible privilege to work
with with these very smart people on the
project so it's some lessons from
alphago maybe so one might argue okay
this can really only solve one problem
the game of goal and it's a fairly
specific problem so maybe in contrast to
what I said earlier but really we have a
very generic planning architecture that
combines the insights that neural
networks can deliver with the systematic
search that Monte Carlo tree search
gives us and this combination of
learning from data and planning leads to
these phenomenal results that some
people within this narrow domain might
even call creativity emerging the key
really is that we took human data at the
beginning and have the system learned
from those human data and then used the
self play mechanism in order to to
bootstrap that and get the player even
stronger beyond human performance
eventually and what we can see here is
really also from the reactions of the
professional players that now they view
this AI as a tool and they
are super excited to see what it comes
up with in the domain that they've all
invested so much lifetime into and and
it was really good to see that I
sometimes you know in the press you see
is remarks then okay this is approaching
artificial general intelligence or
something like that of course that is
all nonsense and I would like to
delineate a little more precisely what
has been achieved here by saying what
hasn't been achieved of course a goal is
is a game where everything is fully
observable whereas the world isn't such
it's usually only very partially
observable in goal we know the model of
the environment we know exactly the
rules of the game whereas in the real
world we don't in the real world there's
typically more than just two ages not
just black and white so that certainly
creates more complex situations the real
world is definitely not a zero-sum game
we're not just all the posts to one
another we can work together to create a
bigger pie and so that's definitely
something that wasn't addressed in this
work the dynamics in the real world is
typically very complex continuous noisy
and all of that in contrast to the
simple simplicity of the game and
typically input spaces are much more
high dimensional to think about ization
and our other sense organs and actual
spaces are much richer than just picking
a single roof in a game and finally of
course there are all of these open
questions in artificial intelligence
that weren't addressed here yet it is an
interesting case study because in this
narrow domain this particular approach
has been so inspiring to those who know
this domain ok I would like to wrap up
by just giving you the bigger picture of
this kind of research direction a lot of
work a deep mind is on machine learning
and I think in general we can say that
machine learning has been one of the big
driving forces of what we now call AI
research but which got a lot of its
roots
machine learning when you look at
multi-agent system there's an additional
component which is the game theoretic
aspect because now you have potentially
cooperative or X as various scenarios
and you need to take into account the
agency of others and game theory is one
of those frameworks that are in a good
position to address these problems
finally we can also learn from cognitive
science and maybe from the social
sciences because they've been busy
studying multi-agent interactions for
many years and certainly on the work I
presented on the emergence of
corporations we've been drawing heavily
on insights from social science as well
so if we look at multi-agent and how it
can help us to achieve AI and make AI
better I think it can really help us
create better AI systems for example if
you think about personal digital
assistants they need to understand what
you want they need to perceive you as an
agent and treat you as an agent this
framework can help us study collective
agent behavior if you look at traffic if
you look at the economy the environment
these are all challenges that can only
be addressed by understanding the
interaction of multiple agents and
finally there are these very important
aspects of AI safety and AI ethics as
the fears move forward and has greater
and greater impact on our world we need
to make sure that it is safe because it
is a powerful technology and we need to
pay put those safeguards in place and we
need to think about the ethical aspects
of AI as well ok thank you very much
[Applause]